foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again
so imagine if you will a largely
forgotten late 80s sort of psychological
horror film that also has sci-fi and
paranormal elements that at times kind
of feels very much like a low budget
Proto Inception uh that also tries to
dabble in as many different subgenres as
possible uh containing flavors of
Altered States
um alien from Beyond Nightmare on Elm
Street
um Haunted House movie like a seance and
possession type movie uh body horror
type flick uh desert road trip slasher
there's a little bit of that in there
too mad scientist kind of thing and then
sprinkle that on top with just a pinch
of lovecrafty and something or other and
you might come close to Imagining the
bizarre what the [ __ ] that is the
1989 movie Nightwish I mean this movie
is kind of like it's like the filmic
equivalent of one of those kind of
trendy like stunt milkshakes or
something like that where it's like hey
let's put an entire slice of red velvet
cake in a blender with a bacon
cheeseburger and some coffee ice cream
and then let's top the whole thing with
like a blueberry filled donut and a dill
pickle and macadamia nuts and like a
[ __ ]
edible tin foil Swan or like you know
whatever it's like it's something like
that and like some fried chicken on top
of it it's like you know like bites of
it are probably delicious and you can't
really help but admire the audacity that
went into making it but you're not
entirely sure all of the parts go
together that's essentially what this
movie is like now I I gotta say I can't
remember exactly why this movie stood
out to me as I was kind of scrolling
through to be looking for films to
review this is an experience I have
quite a bit if you've seen some of my
other reviews like for Cameron's closet
and stuff like I don't think I ever saw
this movie back in the day if I did I
remembered absolutely nothing about it
um I do remember kind of like spotting
the cover at the video store
occasionally again like back in the day
I probably never rented it back then
because I thought it was like a sci-fi
movie because of what the cover looks
like or I thought it was just like gonna
be a ripoff of Dreamscape or maybe the
aforementioned Altered States which it
really isn't I mean except for the Parts
where it kind of is so this movie is
Apparently one of only two directorial
credits for a guy named Bruce R cook who
I guess is actually was more worked in
like writing and editing apparently uh I
read actually a couple few reviews of
this movie that mentioned that he had
done some camera work like he wasn't the
cinematographer but I guess it was like
the camera operator on the Brian yazna
Film Society from 1989 which badass
because that's an awesome movie but if
that is indeed the case
um he didn't mention it on his IMDb like
it's not on his resume on there and he
doesn't have a Wikipedia page I mean
even the Wikipedia page like for
Nightwish the movie does have a
Wikipedia page of its own but it doesn't
even have a plot synopsis it's very very
very scanty uh so that's kind of how
under the radar this thing is now it did
get a nice new blu-ray transfer from
Unearthed records in 2019 and it's a
available on several streaming services
nowadays like I said I watched it on 2B
for free you can also rent it on Amazon
Prime for like three bucks or something
and I think um you know not that I would
ever Advocate this but I think that a
couple people have uploaded it to
YouTube as well but it does seem like
this movie was pretty obscure for a
while there
and I will say that although this movie
is not a masterpiece by any means it's
actually much better than I was
expecting much weirder than it was than
I was expecting that's for sure and it
really does kind of deserve a bigger
audience I mean especially if you know
the audience that you're talking about
is like in the market for kind of like a
somewhat cheesy dream logic kind of
narrative that is essentially just
throwing everything it can think of into
the casserole dish and just kind of like
hoping for the best now in spite of the
relative like fell between the
cracksitude I guess of Nightwish it does
actually have some recognizable actors
in it that I'd seen in other things uh
and it must be said it has some really
good practical Gore effects they were
done by knb you know Greg nicotero and
his uh gang over there uh the optical
effects in there which are kind of like
cgi-ish I don't even think they're CGI
because I think they just like painted
them like they're animated like on the
film they don't look so great but it's
just kind of like par for the course for
this era and for this budgetary very
level like they look as good as you know
similar kind of things now probably the
biggest names in this movie I feel like
are Brian Thompson who probably best
known as night slasher from Cobra that
1986 like Sylvester Stallone movie and
he was also in Fright Night Part Two
like he played Bosworth
um you also have Jack Starrett who was
in Blazing Saddles he was in race with
the devil he was in first Blood
and then kind of rounding out the cast
you have Elizabeth Caton I guess that's
how you pronounce her last name she was
in Silent Night deadly night part two
she was in Friday the 13th part seven uh
the new blood
you have Alicia Das who wasn't in a huge
amount of stuff she did some TV I think
she was on Santa Barbara like that soap
opera and a couple of other things you
have uh Robert Tessier or Tessier I'm
not sure how you pronounce his last name
he was in uh he was in a [ __ ] ton of
stuff like going back a long way he was
in the side Hackers from 1968 which you
know if you've probably seen if you're
an MST fan like I am uh he was in the
Deep the movie that was based on the
Peter benchley novel he was also in Star
crash which is where I recognized him
from uh he also got Tom Dugan who was in
Marked for Death he was in Leprechaun 3
Hellraiser bloodline uh you have Arthur
sybolski or Archer sybulski he was in
The Hunt for Red October among other
things and Clayton Rohner who I
recognize right away he was actually in
just one of the guys I think that was
his first movie he was in April Fool's
Day which I think I've talked about on
my channel before he was also in I
madman which is another movie I have to
get around to doing and The Relic among
the other things he's still working
nowadays matter of fact I think he was
also in human centipede three like if I
remember correctly now I'm gonna try and
give a breakdown of the plot but keep in
mind that it's probably not going to
make a lot of sense uh just be assured
that all the stuff that I'm saying
actually does happen in the movie I'm
not just tripping balls or making [ __ ]
up just for the sake of making stuff up
okay okay so we open up on the movie as
a woman who we later learn is named
Donna she kind of comes out of this
fancy party at a mansion at night like
she's walking out of the house and she's
wearing this very like a formal red
dress and carrying her red high-heeled
shoes in her hand and she kind of seems
like she's out on this big lawn and
she's like looking for something it's
like so she comes across like a man's
shoe and then like a bloody piece of
clothing I couldn't tell if it was like
a sock or a shirt or something like that
and then she comes across like a severed
hand so then like as she continues
walking after she's kind of like huh a
severed hand
I hate when you stumble across this ever
hand when you're like walking around but
she eventually comes across like a dude
eating another dude and she starts to
run away and then the cannibal guy like
starts running after her now so she's
able to briefly evade the cannibal by
basically standing just to one side of
him and like counting on his lack of
peripheral vision I guess and then she
takes like one of her shoes and like
throws it over her head and like makes a
noise over there where she's like oh and
he's like distracted you know what I
mean now because of the Ridiculousness
of the setup and because we've seen the
cover and because we've seen uh the kind
of like tagline of the movie which I
think is something like in your dreams
no one can hear you scream or something
like that so we're like immediately
suspicious that this is a dream sequence
and uh before Donna can get munched by
the cannibal uh our supposition is
confirmed because Donna and her perky
wet t-shirt and case boobies uh wake up
in a sort of like sensory deprivation
tag sort of but like it's not really
sensory deprivation because it's just
basically floating in water and like
everybody can just like look in on it
you know what I mean so it's not the
same thing so she has like electrodes on
her head and we see that she's actually
in like a lab setting there's a bunch of
her colleagues standing around in white
coats and they're you know presumably
monitoring her progress or whatever it
is she's doing so it's established as we
go on that these are all graduate
students in the parapsychology program
of whatever College this is and they're
being overseen by their Professor who I
don't think is ever named but is very
clearly a weirdo now it seems like the
project that they're working on
has to do with controlling dreams and in
particular seeing what will happen to
you like if you die in your dream like
if that would rid your waking self of
all fear of death or something like that
I'm not entirely clear on it but I'm
probably going to say that a lot just
telling you right now so like here's
where the homage to A Nightmare on Elm
Street kind of comes into play but I
don't want to like accuse it of being a
rip-off of that because this movie is
just such a crazy like Patchwork quilt
of influences that you can't really just
accuse it of ripping off one thing
because it's pretty much ripping off all
the things you know what I mean and then
becoming its own kind of like crazy
gumbo in the process
so the professor actually seems a little
bit miffed that Donna
woke up before like the cannibal in the
dream could eat her so there's kind of
like a little bit of back and forth
about you know maybe there's something
preventing you know these students test
subjects because you know it's said that
like the other students had done it as
well from going all the way past the
threshold of death in their dreams like
maybe their brain is preventing them
from doing it or something like that
like I said it wasn't entirely clear on
it but never mind that because evidently
all this lab work that they're doing
about dreams is just kind of like a
preamble for this Big Field experiment
that they're setting out on the details
of which gotta say are very very murky
so you got three of the students you got
Donna you got Jack who's that's Clayton
renner's character and Kim which is
Alicia das's character and they're
riding in this van driven by this
sociopathic chunk head named Dean who's
played by Brian Thompson who basically
goes out of his way to like run over
bunny rabbits in the road like on
purpose
um molest Kim at pretty much every
opportunity even though she sometimes
seems to be into it for I'm not really
sure and kind of like does weird [ __ ]
like making these animalistic like
grunting noises just to be obnoxious I
mean it's it's something I'm not
actually entirely sure what the point of
Dean's character is because he could
literally be removed from the movie
without it making a lick of difference
to the plot but I'll get a little bit
more into that later on so the gang are
heading out into the desert to this
apparently long abandoned cabin Mansion
type deal
where supposedly every conceivable
horror and Supernatural Trope in the
world has happened at some point or
another
not only is there an element of like Eco
horror like in that there are kind of
poisons or mineral elements or something
like in the water supply in the area
that caused like at some point in the
past widespread deaths like mutations
and the animals and the people
intellectual disabilities like birth
defects things like that but there have
also been reports of UFOs in the area
there's local uh tribal legends about
Ancient Aliens there's more tribal
legends about monsters like coming out
of the ground there's stories about this
house in particular being haunted by the
ghost of a little boy who died in an
earthquake
then there's the father of the same
little boy who's kind of like a shitty
Robber Baron type dude who built the
house over a mine that he ran uh oh and
he was also exploiting like all the
native workers like in the mind you know
what I mean and some of them died in
there as well and the guy that owned the
mine also conducted seances and Satanic
rituals in the house which may or may
not have summoned a demonic entity or
entities did I forget anything probably
so a lot of this Exposition is laid out
as the students are like driving to this
place in a van like I said like over the
desert now presumably the professor and
the remaining student whose name is Bill
got there ahead of them like to set
everything up because they're not in the
van
now before the Scooby gang get to the
house cabin Mansion deal though there's
kind of like this long scene where they
arrive at the gate house it's kind of
like a barn-ish but Shack but with pigs
I don't really know so it's they call it
the Gatehouse though so that's what I'm
gonna call it now so they get there and
they find out that the professor hasn't
left the gate unlocked like he said he
would so Dean has to like climb over the
fence and like bust into the Gatehouse
to get the keys so he can open the gate
and drive the van through and then when
he's in there he meets this mentally
challenged man named Wendell who's
played by Tom Dugan who apparently takes
care of the house and these farm animals
that are there because reasons
um you know and he's like eating corn
flakes out about like Kellogg's Corn
Flakes and also like throwing them to
the animals which you don't really see
until later like so it just looks like
he's throwing them around in the yard
it's like really really weird so the van
group finally get to the main house and
they set up their equipment doing kind
of like vaguely parapsychological stuff
we're degaussing things we're taking
temperature readings all that kind of
stuff like you see on the ghost hunting
shows now Dean the chunk head
um he's apparently not one of the grad
students because he just drops them off
at the house and then he says he'll be
back later to pick them up so like every
now and then as the movie is unfolding
and getting crazier and crazier they'll
be like a random scene of Dean just like
driving the van like through the desert
like listening to the radio and [ __ ] and
I'm not really entirely sure like what
purpose this serves I mean I'm guessing
that um you know Bruce R cook the writer
director I'm guessing he wanted the grad
students to get dropped off at this
house so there wouldn't be a vehicle
there like for them to escape in
possibly but I think I could have found
some like other way around that rather
than adding this entire character who
doesn't really seem to need to be there
and doesn't really factor into the plot
in any way but I don't know that seems
like a weird thing to complain about
when everything in this movie like is
just completely nonsensical but you know
there it is back at the Mansion though
the professor leads the students in a
seance which immediately seems to be
working out like really really well you
know because like all the cameras and
stuff start going Hayward like the
Polaroids taking pictures by it itself
like the doors like slam it open and
closed and all this other kind of stuff
and then this like bright green glow
starts emanating out of the fireplace
and shortly after that this kind of like
glowing green animated CGI snake or
something like comes out the fireplace
and it seems to be interested in Kim
particularly
but before it can do anything like Donna
freaks out and hits it with her purse
which seems to like smush it but then it
just kind of disappears and then there's
like no trace of it left behind like it
was ghostly or some [ __ ] so after that
whole traumatic uh situation the
professor and Bill reveal that all this
stuff like with the door and the
equipment like the camera taking
pictures by itself and stuff was faked
because the professor wanted to see how
they would react to like Paranormal
stuff going on I'm presuming but he does
concede that the ectoplasm which I'm
guessing means like the green animated
snake was real
but this admission that he makes
um it's not even entirely solid uh
anyway because as the evening goes on
the professor keeps making several
references to the entity in the house
and how it's able to cause
hallucinations and he also keeps telling
the students to not trust one another
and to watch each other for signs of
irrational Behavior so it's almost kind
of like they're doing they're almost
doing like a paranoia thing like the
thing you know what I mean like you
don't know
you know if somebody's just like seeing
things or if you're seeing things and
[ __ ] like that so they're kind of trying
to like sew a sort of like mistrust in
the viewer I guess turns out though
speaking of irrational behavior that
it's probably the professor that they
should have been keeping an eye on this
whole time because uh he appears to be a
wee bit of a lunatic just just a tad so
like at one point he handcuffs all the
students and himself to the walls I'm
not entirely sure how he managed that
um and he attempts to summon the entity
whatever it is with a pentagram like
drawn on the floor so like I said
there's like satanic [ __ ] in here too
now this sort of works because like a
green light tornado kind of thing like
comes out of the dirt like comes out of
the um the floor but Bill like wigs out
and pees himself and like he literally
pees himself and screams for the entity
to go back where it came from
um the professor gets mad because he's
like you know that was the only time we
actually summited he [ __ ] it up and
then he seems to like stab Bill to death
like in the stomach
um and then it's also revealed that the
professor has like another previously
unknown like Confederate in the form of
this big hulking like bald dude who's
also mentally challenged because I'm
guessing they're making a reference back
to you know the stuff in the water in
this area like making everybody have
birth defects and be like intellectually
challenged and whatnot so I guess it's
that but this guy's name is uh Stanley
he's played by Robert Tessier Tessier or
Tessier and he's kind of like the
professor's muscle I guess uh so yeah so
he takes away Bill's body we presume and
also at some point like when Jack does
something to piss him off he comes in
and like cuts off one of the fingers on
Jack's right hand although in some
scenes it's his left hand so so as the
movie goes on uh the surviving students
like you know do various things like
they get chased by Stanley and are
eventually forced to participate in the
professor's mystifying experiment
whatever the [ __ ] it is and so sometimes
even though like all this crazy [ __ ] is
happening they don't seem all that mad
at him or they don't seem to be like
ganging up on him like Hey we gotta get
out of here or anything it's like really
really weird like totally yeah so I
don't really know what the end game is
here now like some of the things that
happen like in this kind of middle part
of the movie like in the attic for
example Jack and Donna I think it was
see the ghost of the little boy who died
in the earthquake like that they
mentioned earlier but he's never
mentioned again like they see him one
time and they see him like get smushed
and then he disappears
um the supposedly dead Bill who got
stabbed he returns to life at one point
like toward the end but maybe not
because he might just be housing some
gooey alien babies and maybe also the
professor is also maybe an alien who's
using the students bodies to incubate
extraterrestrial offspring of his own uh
there's a scene very much like the scene
from Alien like where Ripley finds all
the humans like attached to the walls
and like covered with slime they're like
incubating alien babies and whatnot at
one point like Bill falls to the ground
his skull or he gets his skull cracked
open by Kim and bugs come out
um there's one scene where Jack seems to
like be in two places at once and in one
of the places that he's at he actually
like encases Donna's head in a clear
plastic box that is by the way also
filled with tarantulas
um Dean actually eventually like arrives
back at the house like to pick up the
students and he actually like stops at
the Gatehouse and he finds Wendell dead
it looks like he hanged himself but then
he also has like alien [ __ ] like all
over his back like it looks like it's
it's all body horror and gross and then
once Dean gets to the regular house like
Kim finds him later and he's still alive
but his arms and legs have been cut off
and like he has like alien boils like
all over him like again like he's
incubating alien babies so Kim is the
only one that ends up escaping uh even
though she appears to have totally lost
it and seemingly believes everybody else
has been taken over by aliens even
though they keep telling her no all of
this is hallucinations so she hops in
Dean's van
because everyone else is dead apparently
or she thinks they're aliens or whatever
and she speeds off and then like the
green ectoplasm snake thing like twines
itself around her Limbs and it causes
her to drive the van off a cliff now if
you've been following this movie at all
which good luck to you I'm just telling
you that right now but if you've kind of
like gotten in the vibe of this movie
it will not surprise you uh that just
like at the beginning of the movie uh
the whole thing was a dream because
right after Kim like drives the van off
the cliff she wakes up in the same
sensory deprivation tank deal as Donna
did before and everybody is standing in
the lab like totally alive and well
including like some of the other
peripheral characters like Stanley who's
like a janitor in this reality and like
other you know what I mean it's kind of
like a it's kind of like the end of
Wizard of Oz where it's like and you
were there and you were there you know
what I mean like everybody's playing
different roles it's that kind of
situation however though this ending is
also like the it was all a dream you
know what I mean but this is also kind
of like a fake out because Kim
immediately starts to suspect even
though she just woke up in the lab that
she's still dreaming and she's like gets
up and she's acting all paranoid and
then she opens the door to go out of the
lab presumably but then there's like
another door just like that one like
behind it and then there's another one
behind that and then she opens it and
then she sees that green light again and
then there's Stanley like covered with
blood and menacing her and like Donna is
all like hanging up with her guts hanger
or something like that so I'm guessing
Okay I'm not really sure this is how I
read it and I'm not sure if this is
correct or even if correct me it has any
meaning in this situation I'm thought
that we were led to assume or we were
meant to conclude rather that because
Kim had finally died by going off the
cliff in the van like in Her Dream
because I guess the whole movie was a
dream or was it I don't know really it's
one of those kind of situations but I'm
guessing because she died in the dream
like now she's stuck in this nightmare
forever and like she can't get out I
mean I don't know
um that's how I interpreted it but
Nightwish definitely seems like the kind
of movie where
arguments could really be made for
pretty much any potential interpretation
that you would care to come up with I
mean it really is that bad [ __ ] you
could really argue that the whole entire
thing was a dream like even the stuff
with like inside the lab and everything
like that but I don't know does it
matter I guess not now I did feel that
the whole is it a dream or not vibe that
whole narrative I think that that was
mostly used to kind of justify
just tossing a bunch of kind of cool but
random tropes into the pot and also kind
of like just a paper over any
inconsistencies in the script like I
said you know where Jack gets one of his
fingers cut off and it's like it's
clearly on his right hand but then like
in a scene or two layers on his left
hand and if you pointed that out it's
like oh that was a continuity error
they'll be like no no it was a dream
that's how he were you know what I mean
so it's just kind of like if you say it
was a dream then all bets are off then
you don't really have then nothing has
to make any sense so I do kind of feel
like they were leaning on that a little
bit but all that said I can't deny that
this movie was actually pretty
entertaining even though I you know I
gotta admit I would be lying if I said
that I had the faintest idea what the
[ __ ] was going on in this thing but
through most of the movie I mean it's
it's baffling it's baffling
um now the effects in it like
particularly the body horror and like
the alien stuff are actually really good
um and a lot of the cinematography and
like the shot compositions and stuff
like that were way better than they had
any right to be like in a movie with
this low of a budget
um there was all also a lot of
gratuitous nudity like if you're into
that so you know both the both the
ladies show their boobies at some point
you know and I know some people like
that and they're nice boobies so there's
that now I will say that the acting was
a little bit uneven uh I could have done
without the dean character because and
nothing against that actor because I do
like that actor but you know he was just
like this annoying chode whose presence
in the movie was completely Superfluous
like he was just he didn't like factor
into the plot at all
um but other than that like overall this
was a pretty fun if like I said kind of
baffling
slice of late 80s weirdness that I kind
of feel like could not have been made in
any other era than when it was made you
know what I'm saying it's so so 80s and
it's just so bizarre and even though not
all of it works I kind of feel like this
this kind of thing is like cool to come
across because it's just like this
bizarre ass movie that most people
probably haven't even seen or heard of
and it's always kind of nice to find
something like that even if it's not you
know a big Masterpiece or anything like
that I would kind of recommend it if you
like stuff like
um you know if you like like Stuart
Gordon stuff or Brian yesna's kind of
stuff maybe like Wes Craven a little bit
maybe even Ken Russell it's not quite as
out there as Ken Russell but it's along
those lines like I said it's kind of
like has some Altered States if Altered
States was like way cheesier and then
also had like Stuart Gordon kind of
stuff where it's like I don't even want
to say it's lovecrafty and it's not
quite lovecrafty and it has like a
slight slight edge of lovecraftian in it
but not exactly but it's like I said
it's kind of like all movies and no
movies there's just so much stuff going
on it's like I don't even think that I
scratched the surface of all the [ __ ]
that's going on in this movie and I
can't really understand like why
I don't know it just seemed like I'm
only gonna make like maybe the guy
thought I'm only gonna make one movie
like you know in my life so I'm just
gonna put everything in it because it
definitely has that feel to it where
it's just like you know it it's one
thing to say oh it's aliens or something
like that but it's like no I want aliens
and dreams and seances and satanists and
possession and you know and haunted
house and like all this other I mean it
was everything everything was in there I
can't think of a single sub-genre
there's even like a slasher kind of
element to it too like a Hills Have Eyes
not every Hill well it is kind of like
hills have eyes because of all the
mutations and all that kind of stuff
like in the desert so it's like I can't
think of really like a single subgenre
that they did not touch on in this movie
in one way or another which is actually
kind of an impressive fee like now that
you think of it now that I think about
it so that will do it for this flickers
of here hope you guys enjoyed it I'll
see you guys again on the next one bye